foreign
[Music]
game this might be our last depending on
who we play 2192 Christopher 171. all
right Christopher let's play
well we got to play king's Indian since
this is virtually our last game
we are definitely going to play
a king's Indian which is
the OG opening this is what I started
the speedrun with this is what I played
my whole life
and we have faced it probably more from
the white side than to the black side
uh in the speedrun so it's about time we
we paid homage to it from the black side
and of course F3 which is one of my top
recommendations from White uh this is
the same-ish variation named after uh I
believe German or Austrian don't
remember uh Frederick same issue was he
lived to like his 90s he was I think
awarded The Grandmaster title late in
life by fide he was a very strong player
um not not top five in the world but he
was he was a big opening guy and he sort
of developed a lot of these systems
including and he developed a lot of
systems connected with the move F3 the
same the move F3 and the nimso Indian is
also called the same ish so against the
same-ish black has literally a gazillion
viable continuations and depending on
the level of the player that I'm
teaching you know I'd recommend
different stuff with black against the
same-ish
uh the line that I actually play now
most of these lines start by Castle you
start by castling this is automatic
generally white plays Bishop E3 although
I can also play Knight E2 these moves
often transpose into each other
uh and the point of F3 is usually
twofold the first is to safeguard the
point is to safeguard E4 but it's also
in many cases of course to prepare the
king Side Pawn storm with G2 G4
so the drawback of course is that you
don't you aren't able to access the F3
Square for your knight and so Knight G2
is the result of that
Okay so
I'm trying to decide what I want to play
I what I want to play in this game is an
old line This is the line that I kind of
grew up playing it's it's gotten less
popular it's gotten less popular over
the years it was played prolifically by
Gary Kasparov I played it a lot myself
when I was around 22 2300 there's
nothing inherently wrong with the system
black is worse if white is incredibly
accurate but a lot of people don't study
it so nowadays
black kings Indian players mainly play
one of two lines they either play the
sort of benoni uh benoni structure with
C5 this is often considered the best
line against the samish objectively and
the second popular line is the Pono
system which is Knight C6 and then A6
you've probably seen me play it in Blitz
Rook B8 and then B5
but the old move is of course E5 which
is also the traditional way to play The
King's Indian and a lot of people think
oh against the same issue can't play E5
not true at all E5 is a totally viable
line and it frequently slips through the
calves oh boo and this of course is one
of the drawbacks white has this move d e
which takes all of the fun out of the
game
but that's okay you got to learn how to
play these types of positions as well
okay so end game
this is kind of a version of The
Exchange variation
and I will fully confess that I'm not a
big specialist in this particular
position this is probably the first time
I have this
in my life
so
how are we going to proceed here well
the first thing to understand is that
Knight takes D5 is not forced the
problem with Knight takes D5 is that
white recaptures with the c pawn and
what happens as a result of that well as
a result of that there appears a Pawn on
D5 which greatly
uh hampers are queen side development it
it controls C6 it controls E6
and the traditional treatment here is
Knight 65 CD and then C6 trying to get
rid of that pawn but if you can
visualize that position in your mind the
knight from E2 can slide over to C3
and then you're in a tough spot again
because if you take the pawn on D5 the
pawn is replaced by a bloodthirsty
Knight so as annoying as the Knight on
D5 looks it's not actually that scary
what is it doing it's attacking C7 we
have to defend that pawn we can't play
C6 because still the Knight jumps into
C7 and traps the rook and if you play
The King's Indian you know that the
traditional developing Square for the B8
Knight is on A6 so that's the move we
are going to choose I hope I'm not
walking into some sort of deep
preparation we're going to play Knight
A6 protecting the pawn from the side
and if white plays Bishop G5 which is a
move that probably scares you if you're
not experienced then you have to move
Rook d8 D6
simultaneously getting out of the pin
and protecting the Knight on F6
the long-term prospects here are in
Black's favor and largely that is
because these pawns on C4 and E4 which
is a very typical
formation for the king's Indian when
white trades off the D4 Pawn as a result
of that white accepts a huge gaping
weakness on T4 and in general if you
look at the center squares most of them
are under Black's control if we're able
to get this Knight off of D5 we're going
to have full control over a whole host
of key Central squares I'm talking D4 D3
is another very weak square that we can
easily access with our Knight C2 E3 the
entire complex of squares in the center
is very very weak so it's currently
masked by this imposing Knight on D5 but
if we're able to play C6 and Chase the
Knight away if we're able to get white
to trade on F6 black is going to be
solidly better and I've won a ton of
games like this throughout my life and
I'll show you a kind of traditional loss
in this line afterward after the game I
think our opponent is correctly taking
his time and Bishop G5 Rook D6 very
important resource otherwise we lose an
exchange
Bishop G5 is on the board
now take note of the fact that sometimes
giving up an exchanger is not the end of
the world Knight 65 doesn't lose the
game on the spot because after Bishop
takes the eight the Knight can try to
jump into E3
but all of this is a total moot point
because Rook D6 is perfectly sufficient
and once again you might be like well
this is just heading toward a draw right
why I can just trade everything on F6
and then make a draw not so that
resulting end game is full of life and
it can be played for an advantage with
black I don't think white is worse here
if white is very accurate but most
players ultimately end up in such
positions relinquishing the initiative
and then falling prey to a plan that
involves grabbing control of these key
Center squares
so our opponent is pondering his next
move
a couple of things
note that the fundamental asymmetry in
this position consists in the fact that
we have not pushed our sepon up to C5
that's why positionally black is better
here because we reserve the possibility
a possibility we're going to exploit
right now of pushing the pawn up to C6
controlling the D5 Square white cannot
exercise the same control over the
Square that's reflected about the center
which is D4 and that's why positionally
white is often in a lot of trouble in
these positions
yeah 97 check and Knight takes C8 is
possible but our Bishop on C8 is not an
integral integral piece yeah we'd love
we'd love to keep our Bishop if possible
but the heavy lifting is going to be
done by the Knight on A6 that's this
piece is going to do the heavy lifting
what kind of heavy lifting is it going
to do well it's ultimately going to try
to situate itself on D4 and you can do
that in a variety of ways Knight B4
Knight c294 but the more traditional
Maneuvers are either Knight C7 or Knight
C5
and then back to E6 and again toward D4
which doesn't mean we're just blindly
closing our eyes and playing these three
moves we're gonna do other stuff as well
depending on what our opponent plays
also from a yeah from an opening rules
perspective
and white has spent like a gazillion
moves with this Knight
and okay he's taken the bishop and
gotten the bishop pair but this bishop
on F1 is not exactly you know all that
impressive it's just sort of staring at
the pot if white could push the pawn to
C5 here that would be a total Game
Changer does night before have any Merit
absolutely it does yeah Knight before is
probably our next move if it is
permitted if it's if I play C5 we take
it with the Knight
that's that's why we positioned our
Knight on A6 partially it was to prevent
white from playing C5
so probably the best move for white here
and this is not an easy move you know
anybody to play is Bishop G5 to E3
trying to restrict the Knight on A6 as
much as possible and of course to
prepare C5 what is the move C5 do it
opens up the bishop on F1 why is that
important because potentially if we
don't move our Knight away from A6 the
Knight is going to be captured our
structure is going to be ruined and
getting the other Knight to D4 while
still possible is going to be a lot more
cumbersome of a process right it's going
to take like four moves
so white has a couple of ways to try to
prepare C5 but against all of them we
have a very important retreating move
that's going to help us prevent it but
Bishop B2 is the game continuation which
I'm happy to see
well the most obvious move the most
tempting move for most people is of
course going to be night before
but I think in this particular version
night before is a bit of a dead end
because after a night before let's say
white plays Rook C1
we can play an ID3 check but as I just
pointed out we don't actually want to
trade this Knight unless we trade it for
something on the D4 Square so that it
can be replaced with an even stronger
pot
so if we were to move the Knight I would
position I would play Knight C5 or
Knight C7 96 but because white hasn't
prepared C5 we don't actually need to
rush we can take care of some other
facets and aspects of our position first
before moving our Knight to the
appropriate scores let me think about
this for a second
I have an interesting positional idea
unfortunately it sort of fails
concretely
but the interesting move that I have in
mind here
is I I know I just mentioned that moving
the other night toward D4 can be a
longer process but for some reason I
really like the move Knight F6 to D7
and it's not the easiest move to explain
basically your first and foremost
covering the C5 score one more time
you're also opening up the bishop so
when you get either of the knights
toward to D4 the bishop is going to be
playing a role in supporting that Knight
if that makes sense the Knight on F6 is
a little bit awkward here it's
disrupting the coordination of our
pieces it's a piece that we constantly
have to babysit so I like the move
Knight F6 to D7 here
in order to lend maximum amount of
energy to the knights now both of our
Knights can access the D4 Square
depending on how white
replies
maybe not the best move but
you very often see this move in the
king's Indian Knight F6 to D7
we could have also considered laying 98
Knight C7 and 96 but this is a little
bit more efficient because it also
covers the C5 Square
hopefully this is making some degree of
sense
of course A Dream
for us would be to trade the dark
squared Bishops if we traded the dark
squirt Bishops then the D4 Square would
just be hours for all of eternity we
would be able to like hang our hat on
that square
for you know the rest of the game
unfortunately it's not so easy to trade
dark squared Bishop you might say well
what about Bishop F6 any player worth
their salt isn't going to accept that
trade Bishop F6 actually just encourages
white to drop the bishop back to E3 a
move that he might play anyway
so important in such closed positions
not just assume that your opponent is
going to do the traits that you want him
to do
and Bishop F6 is still an interesting
move
but not because I'm expecting the
Bishops to get traded but rather because
we can head to B6 with our dark Square
Bishop another positive byproduct of the
move Knight D7
is F5 an idea no F5 is not an idea here
because
when you are coming up with a move like
F5 you always want to ask yourself well
who benefits from the position getting
opened up it's generally not the side
that has control over key Central
squares right we don't want any
distractions we don't want any
distractions in the sense of the
position opening up and then we have to
deal with new weaknesses we want the
position to stay close that we can
single in a single-minded manner focus
on
essentially getting control of this
Square okay
G4 I mean this move doesn't really
accomplish anything it actually just
weakens another Square enough on F4 so
I'm already considering some sort of
arrangement where one Knight heads
toward F4 and then the other night heads
toward D4 that's way in the future
though we're not there yet so my
instinct here is to continue with our
plan and to play Knight D to C5 also
yeah Knight B4 is now a sexier
significantly sexier move now that our
other night is ready to jump into the
support with Knight C5
in fact I really like night before here
and I think night before might be the
most efficient way
of getting the Knight around to D4
now you might say well I just remember
you saying that after night before Rook
C1 were at a dead end well the situation
has changed because after night before
Rook C1 the other night jumps into C5
and suddenly we're threatening a fork on
D3 and we can also use the D3 Square as
a Transit point
to head for F4 the square that white has
just weakened there is one complication
though so just give me a second
there's just one like concrete variation
that I can't quite get to get to work
so maybe we'll go for the more mundane
Knight dc5
hmm
okay you know what I'm gonna just follow
my intuition here let's go now 94 cannot
be wrong this is the kind of move that
it's got to be at least okay
now a lot of you are probably thinking
after Rook C1 once again to go Knight D3
check but again I repeat Knights are
more valuable than Bishops in this
position because the center is closed
and you can think of the Knight as kind
of a screwdriver it can really access
it's like a Phillips screwdriver going
to really get into the right into into
you know these small spaces much better
than a bishop can
you're like flossing the board a little
bit
I can Castle the point of night before
is not to Fork we're not expecting white
to miss the fork the point is to use
before as a Transit point and eventually
head either for F4 or something our
opponent is just
disallowed to D4
okay so let's proceed with Knight C5 as
as we have planned
now we're once again threading a fork
and our other point is to drop the
Knight back toward E6 and finally we're
able to get a knight to D4 which is the
first big step toward winning this game
is achieving our general plan of
centralizing our night
doesn't mean that the game ends
immediately right you put a knight on D4
and white just turns into dust but you
cannot win such positions in like three
moves that you have to do it step by
step and you have to celebrate the small
victories that's the most important part
that's the most important part
so somebody asked what makes the D4
Square important that sort of is is a
question you know to understand that you
have to understand the rudiments of like
Square control in general so in general
controlling a a square in the center is
good right that's an inherently good
thing because Knight's in the center
maximize their control over the board
right a knight in the center controls
eight squares a knight on the side of
the board on h8 controls two squares now
not all squares in the center are
equally important all of the time but in
this particular instance a knight on D4
just Lords over the whole position I
don't really know exactly how to explain
it in a very understandable way but
Knight on D4 just sort of dominates the
board
we might be tempted by Knight bd3 but
that is what gave me pause earlier if
you play Knight bd3 here then after the
move Rook C to D1 all of a sudden we've
pinned ourselves ourselves
and to make matters worse we aren't able
to double Rooks on the D file because
the bishop controls that square
that's a little bit iffy I don't see any
compelling reason not to
drop the Knight back to you especially
because this is a move that comes with
Tempo attacks the bishop forces it out
of G5 and makes possible in the future
the doubling of the Rooks on the D file
a valuable additional potential resource
now there is one drawback that also gave
me pause the drawback of the way that
we're playing this is that after we
situate our Knight on D4 because we've
moved the other night away from Asics
and this is where I actually think if
I'm totally honest I think we should
have gone Knight C5 I think we should
have skipped the move Knight before
entirely this was impulsive
because imagine the same exact situation
with the Knights still sitting on A6
what move
would we have prevented not a big deal
this is not a game changer it's just a
subtle thing
what would be impossible after Knight T4
who can tell me and we're going to play
this move anyway we're
I'm team Knight D4
what would the Knight on A6 have still
been preventing yes C5 and C5 as we
already know is a potentially annoying
move that opens up another front and
gives white some counter play White is
still solidly worse but had we kept the
Knight on A6 we would have limited why
it's counter play entirely
now after C5 we kind of need to think on
our feet
and I have some ideas there but we'll
need to figure something out after C5
a question that I can answer as the game
goes on HDL is asking why Knight D4 and
not Knight F4 so the Queens are off the
board so you're not going to Checkmate
the white king here your thoughts should
be as far removed from like attacking
the king as possible in addition Knight
F4 is just a very big blunder because it
allows Bishop C5
and you always have to
anytime you have a rook and a king in
alignment and your opponent has the
bishop of that color you need to be
careful
so I've made a mental note to myself
okay if I ever move the Knight away from
D4 for for whatever reason I'm going to
make sure that I won't forget about
preventing Bishop C5
yeah we could have played B6 here but
that would be a little too slow and it
would create kind of a general
brittleness in our Queen Side Pawn
structure and it will allow a way to
play A3 and B4
um and then C5 would be a more explosive
idea
I actually think C5 here is not scary at
all because it also comes with a price
tag right it blunts the bishop even
further and it creates even more
weaknesses on the queen side and we have
many ways to meet C5
we have yeah if you forget your mental
note well that's join the club
yeah the Harmony in our pieces is really
really nice here this is just a great
position
and after C5 we have a choice of several
moves that I really like he goes for cup
D1 and that is a blunder I think no it's
not a blender or is it there I think a
herb on a blundered this move but
luckily for white this turns out
positively we have a move that almost
works it almost wins the game but in
fact it loses
what you should notice is the bishop on
E2 is what I call a type 2 undefended
piece it's only defended by one other
piece and it's also a forkable square so
if you land a knight there that'll be a
fork so of course Knight takes A2 comes
to mind unfortunately after Knight takes
A2 white can play Bishop takes D4
you know so big deal I just take the
bishop but but then white can already
take the 992 we don't have our Knight on
D4 any longer I might say but Knight
takes A2 Bishop takes D4 I can take the
Rook first
and then I can recapture the bishop also
doesn't work because after you take the
Rook we made that mental note white has
that Bishop C5 move attacking The Rook
from two different sources and the
bishop on E2 is still protected by the
Knight on C3 white ends up winning a
piece I'll show that after the game
sadly Knight takes A2 doesn't work
but instead we should continue improving
our position and what is the absolute
simplest way of improving our position
if you're confused and you're not
visualizing it don't worry I will show
this after the game again so don't feel
like you have to visualize every move I
say
I think the simplest is just to play
Rook cd8 I wouldn't play C5 here because
that weakens the D5 score we certainly
don't want to create a symmetrical
weakness for white to exploit
yeah I think Rook cd8 is simple and good
it also creates a threat it threatens
Knight takes C2 check
it threatens Knight takes C2 check
because after Knight takes C2 then we
won The Rook under one
so you know just sort of accumulating
and accumulating the pressure eventually
something is going to give it might not
be on this move sadly Knight takes A2
didn't work fortunate for white
but we're patient and we're already on
the alert tactically because we've
gotten our pieces to excellent squares
White's resources are strained lots of
weaknesses
um but if we don't find anything we can
for example bring this Knight back
around to F4 and with the center being
closed you can you have the time to do
that it's not like anything why it's
about to imminently like do something on
the queen side white should probably
move the king up to avoid Knight takes
C2 being a check
yeah very good move very good move by
Christopher
now my idea is to
continue think of it as just continuing
to turn
the pressure dial up and up and up and
up just by increments now I think we
have the luxury here
of preventing the move C5 I I just I
find C5 to be quite the headache because
it opens up the bishop if you think
about it first after C5 and then white
plays A3 we're gonna have to drop our
Knight back to A6 allowing white to
[ __ ] Our Queen side Bond structure
with Bishop takes C6 now I'll show after
the game that is not a big deal the way
we want to prevent it is not B6 I
already explained why if you play B6
White's gonna play A3 and then B4 and
then whites still
going to be threatening C5
so in reality we're going to make a
retreating move that's going to be
difficult to play for a lot of different
players
we're going to play Knight A6 but
hopefully as I've already explained
Knight A6 isn't just a retreating move
doesn't mean we failed we have succeeded
in installing a knight on D4 the Knight
on B4 has done its job now it's time for
that Knight to assume temporarily a
defensive role what do I mean by that
well it's preventing C5
when the time is right the Knight can
once again assume an aggressive role
heading for F4
another idea that I'm sort of making a
mental note of this bishop on G7 could
be doing more than it's doing
one thing it could be doing is parked on
it could be parked on F6 with the
potential idea of delivering a check on
H4 which could disattach the king from
the bishop and allow certain Knight take
C2 tactics so given another opportunity
I think we're gonna play Bishop F6 if
the time is right and the opportunity
presents itself
but the bishop is also doing a lot just
sitting on G7 it's obviously supporting
the Knight it's a team effort
and both the Rooks and the bishop are
all sort of in service of the night
Bishop F1 okay we weren't going to take
that Bishop anyway so this is a pretty
innocuous move
and I think it gives us the perfect
opportunity to continue doing one of
several things
we can head for F4 with an ic5
and after Knight C5 B4 Knight C E6 yeah
white can play C5 but then our Rook
drops back and remember our Knight used
to be on A6 in that situation which
allowed white to take that night with
the Knight gone from the queen side B4
C5 is a lot less intimidating than it
used to be
on the other hand perhaps we shouldn't
rush with Knight C5 that's a move we can
always play
and I think a really kind of
Advanced end game player would do their
best to induce as many weaknesses as
possible before embarking on like a
concrete plan of action and the move
that really comes to my mind
is Bishop F6
on the other hand that allows the move
G5
and G5 is a weakness
but one thing that worries me is the
prospect of white playing G5 and then
following it up with F4 in order to
undermine the support of this Knight on
D4 especially if the bishop leaves the
h8a1 diagonal
so I actually I'm flip-flopping a little
bit
um and these are not easy decisions like
I genuinely do not know what the best
move is
now that I'm thinking about it I believe
we should play Knight C5 I think we
should embark on our original plan and
get this night around to E6 and then
potentially of course sink its teeth
into the second weak square that white
has created of the move G4 ief4
now should white hold a draw here with
ideal defense absolutely but the tension
continues to accumulate White's clock
dwindles and all of that is part of the
art of converting a small advantage
after Knight C5 b496 thoughts no you
certainly don't want to play F6 and G5
you don't want to bury your own Bishop
alive
and here we don't have to worry about
white playing F4
that's the function of the bishop
sitting on G7
right the function of that Bishop is
that it's fully supporting the Knight
and so it's taking this thing at about
492. okay
good move
doesn't really change our
strategy though
I think we should still drop our Knight
back to E6 supporting the Knight on D
especially because White's played 92. so
we should still continue rerouting
Knight C6
and we're not afraid of the move C5 big
deal we just dropped the Rook back to D7
if white takes on D4 we will have to
decide what we're going to take back
with
but that's a decision to be made if
white takes on we don't need to do that
in advance
so things that I'm thinking about in
terms of improving our position
definitely the move Bishop F6 comes to
mind again and this time Bishop F6 is
even more appetizing because G5 is no
longer possible we now have this 996
stopping G5
so there's this idea for example of
playing Bishop G5 and then Bishop F6 and
Bishop G5 to trade off the dark squared
Bishop which is White's main defensive
piece B4 there we go
big deal I don't care let let white play
C5 we're just going to let that fall by
the wayside
and we are indeed going to play Bishop
F6 we're going to continue with our plan
we're going to continue with our plan
and I assume White's gonna play C5 we're
gonna drop our Rook back and yeah
White's made some modest gains on the
queen side but we have shifted the the
battle the front from the queen side to
the center and the King side so these
moves like B4 and C5 as intimidating as
they appear don't really accomplish all
that much in fact they sometimes maybe
even create more weaknesses
yeah notice that I'm calculating
actually very little I'm doing very
little actual calculation some like
we're doing one or two move lines making
sure for example that C5 doesn't trap
The Rook right if our other Rook had
been on D7 then C5 would have trapped
The Rook on D6 so I'm like making sure
okay I have the D7 Square looking at the
queen side for a bit okay there's
nothing I also in secret calculated
Bishop takes D4 and Knight takes D4
something I didn't share with y'all but
something I'll talk about after the game
Knight G3 and I have to commend our
opponent playing an excellent game this
is making it very difficult for us now I
think we should simply follow our plan
well what did I say our plan was well
our plan consists of several things we
want to install a knight on F4 but there
is a much more substantive achievement
that we could attain here which is of
course to trade this bishop on E3
so much better than playing Knight F4 or
Bishop H4 is to trade White's best piece
which is currently the bishop on E3
white will remain with a light squared
Bishop that is sort of saddled by uh his
own weak pawns also from a logistical
standpoint if you consider Bishop takes
G5 Knight takes you if I might say well
our Knight has gotten derailed well not
really but it's actually doing a lot on
G5 as well it's just attacking the pawn
on F3 which is a backward Pawn
so why do I say the bishop is the best
piece well because the bishop is
controlling F4 it's also helping defend
D4 and this is a blunder this is where
our whole positional campaign turns into
tactics
as you understand the only open file on
the board is the D file it's been
plugged by the Knight on D4 this entire
time but that doesn't mean you've
stopped looking for tactics on the D
file you have to notice that you have a
pair of doubled Rooks white has a rook
under one that's only defended once so
already you should start the wheels
should start circling around in your
mind and you should quickly see the
winning tactic we take the bishop we
lure the king onto a vulnerable spot and
the simple tactic everybody should see
this Knight D4 to C2 check what's funny
is that if white drops the king back to
E2 and says hey now I defend the Rook we
win the game with 96 to F4 check which
is so fitting the Knight F4 finally ends
up and it happens Knight F4 ends up
winning the game we could take the Rook
first also but it really doesn't matter
um it doesn't matter we could start with
Knight F4
the Knight on C2 controls E1 so the King
has to remove itself from the defense of
the rook and the game is over
we're gonna win the exchange and not
only the exchange we're gonna the dam
has been breached so not only are we
going to win The Exchange we're going to
trade White's La other pair of Rook
White's other rook and we're going to
use our Rook just to take all of white
spawns in the second rank
so
28 moves only it seems like a lot more
but these kinds of positional games
that's always what tends to happen is
they feel like a lot but only like you
know 30 moves so what should we do now
well we can keep both of our Rooks on
the board but the simplest approach is
again all of you should just like be
itching to play this move
is Rook D2 check
a pair of Rooks leaving us with one Rook
to zero and just you're just gonna start
like you know picking up whichever Pawn
you want to pick up you can pick up
okay so here we have a clinical move
that ends the game immediately rather
than just grabbing the Knight on E2
immediately you can say okay well the
Knight on E2 is under a lot of pressure
what is it protected by it's protected
by the king you can't check the king
easily but what you can do is dislodge
the bishop away from this diagonal and
that can be done with the move Rook C
two attacking the bishop much better
than taking on E2 and now it's over
because the bishop has to move and then
white loses the Knight or white loses
the bishop and the pawn on E5 defends
the Knight that was a nice game
there we go 22.99
all right
okay let's take a quick look I mean I
explained a lot during the game but I
want to make a couple of substantive
points
we are going to largely skip the opening
phase like we're not going to talk
about the theory of the samish
um
you can do your own research opening
wise
what I will say is that after E5 of
course D takes E5 is not a testing move
at all dt65 leads to a relatively
toothless version of The Exchange
variation it's not a mistake to play D5
but it is not again it's not a testing
move of course the testing line is as
you can probably guess even if you're
not a king's Indian player D5 which
leads to a structure you've seen
probably a million times
this is the classic King's Indian
structure
and the line that I was planning to play
is the move C6
C6 disrupting and trying to cut into
white center but the other idea of this
move you're not legitimately expecting
white to take on C6 nobody's gonna do
that no why would white give away the
spot on D5
the real point of the move C6 is to
trade once on D5 and open up some files
on the queen side anticipating the fact
that white is probably going to Castle
queenside in order to Checkmate black on
the king side
there's an old line that's existed for
many decades Kasparov played it
successfully
and uh White is better like if you look
at this from a modern theoretical
perspective white can even start with
the move Bishop E3 white doesn't have to
hurry D5 because this leads to like a
bad accelerated dragon type structure
not to most Kings Indian players as
likings
so I would have played uh sorry I
wouldn't have played that because I'm
gonna play C6 Here and Now white can
play D5 and again you get the C takes D5
C takes D5 A6 and I've shown some games
on the speedrun in this variation before
I've won some really nice games with
black here
and I could show you know I could show
you like four or five games that I've
won in this line but it's somewhat
beyond the scope of this game this is a
completely different structure
um but I'll just show you one game that
represents a very fond memory I think
this was my second Grand Master win
of course I got gifted this game on a
golden platter
um I got gifted this game on Golden
platter but this is one of my fondest
tournament Memories the the first
Saturday tournament in Budapest which is
a series of Norm tournaments that have
been held now for decades
they have you know a bit of reputation
as kind of a norm Factory but when I
played in the first Saturday which was
only once 2010 uh nothing Shady happened
it was a totally legit tournament
uh with the exception of this GM which
is blundered a piece against me in one
move but here's the game
uh here's the game and it's it's
relevant because it's in this line
so I'm playing Zoltan Varga Hungarian
solid Hungarian GM
so basically
as you can see Bishop e35 there's that
C6 move Queen D2 so Varga plays a
different type of line where he doesn't
play D5 at all he simply keeps the pawn
on D4 and says hey take me give me the
the marozzi by instructor
so we get a cat and mouse game like no
I'm not giving the emergency by
instructor I want you to play D5
and after Castle's the very important
move A6 notice that I'm basically
playing with the anticipation of the
move D5 if White NOW plays D5 you get a
theoretical line cd5 cd5 B5 and you get
sort of classic opposite side castling
white plays G4 black plays B4 you can
analyze this on your own it's
complicated the engine gives a
significant advantage to White if white
is very accurate but in the game he
plays de5 which surprised me
now Knight takes C5 of course White's
idea is that the pawn on D6 is now a
very big weakness but after he plays
Knight T4 there was a reason that I
played A6 and C6 what was that reason
and this is a move that you should
basically be itching to play
automatically with black
no the king's Indian is not even close
to refuted
and you should play this move with no
regard for
the health and safety of your pawns it's
much more important to open up the queen
side than it is to try to Shield your
pawns you have B5
so white plays F4 this was his idea but
after Knight eg4 it turns out that my
peace activity has so often happened to
the king's Indian compensates for the
fact that I'm it looks I'm losing C6
with Tempo but try to look at this
appreciate this position Black's pieces
are on excellent squares White's pieces
are all over the place White's bid
enough more than you can chew
so he was forced to play this move E5
sacrificing the pawn back okay there
were some really complicated tactics
here I could go into them but let me
just show you the blunder at the end of
the day we liquidated
we traded a bunch of pieces and I got an
advantage
so we got this position of course black
is slightly better I've got the better
Bishop he's got the weak King and after
Queen D3 Queen E5 he shocks me the move
Queen D4
like I couldn't believe that he actually
played this who can give me the entire
refutation it's not just one move
he did not miss the next move he missed
the third move of the line which is
still stunning but Queen D4 was just
crazy
people Miss retreating moves it's normal
people Miss retreating moves
no no no no no no no not Rook seating
Queen F5 come on Rook seating Queen F5
is sloppy
because remember anytime you have a
situation like this you have to ask
yourself can the piece that is being
attacked also block the check so you
have to remember Queen D3 yeah Queen C7
Chuck Queen C5 and now suddenly he
resigned after Queen C7 you take it and
you go Rook AC and you went pick up the
bishop on C5 so this is just one of many
like
positive memories in the C5 C6 line and
that's why I wanted to play it but back
we go to the Speed Run game which took a
completely different direction
which took a completely different
direction because instead of D5 or
Bishop E3 white takes on E5 legitimate
line I mean this is this exists it's the
theoretical line
but it's quite as far as I know rather
toothless we responded with the move
Knight A6 and just to
make sure that we're all on the same
page the reason that I didn't love
Knight takes D5 and C6 which I see is
the main line actually so probably I
misjudged this position
uh I didn't like the move Knight C3 and
it should make sense to you why this
position is a little bit nasty for black
like it should you should be looking at
this thing yeah I understand why white
is the only one playing for a small edge
here because this Knight is an
incredibly strong night night C7 is
threatened the king's Indian Bishop is
just kind of sag
and white structure is super compact
it's like no weaknesses good position I
would say maybe plus 0.2 small advantage
to White Knight A6 keeps a little bit
more zest in the position and it allows
this later on in the game if we can
repel White's initiative to start
exploiting these weak squares so Bishop
G5 makes sense the way white needs to
play this white needs to play for the
initiative right because if y doesn't
convert the initiative into something
tangible we're going to chase the Knight
out of D5 much like we did and we're
going to start massaging these weak
Centers Square so I actually think
Knight EC3 As Natural as this move is
maybe is a step in the wrong direction
maybe is a step in the wrong direction I
still think the position is objectively
probably equal but what I would do here
with white is just Castle Queens I would
Castle Queen side
and Castle Queen side the main function
of this move is it prevents C6 it
prevents why does it prevent C because
97 check wins The Rook on D6 so I think
castles would have made it a lot more
difficult for black to to carry out the
the plan of playing C6 and getting this
Knight out of T5 and the classic uh
approach in such positions with black if
you play the Kings Indian
a lot you should know this the way the
black generally deals with this is
Knight F6 to E8
and this is a an idea that you should be
aware of it exists across many different
openings
one random memory that comes to mind
maybe too much of a tangent but just to
hammer this home this type of idea also
is common in the closed Sicilian
you might say like what close it's only
totally different opening so close to
ceiling is one white plays Knight C3 and
G3 against this zone closed because
white doesn't open up the center with D4
which is the open soon now the closest
cylinder is a very typical idea what the
white has
so black let's say play is the main
setup
and let's say white plays Bishop E3
we're gonna get just sort of a a random
non-theoretical position
so what you'll often see if black plays
the move
Knight D4 too early so let's say Knight
E7
let's say 92
so let's say we have a position like
this and let's say in this position
black plays Knight T4
so here
I was taught many years ago this
interesting plan by my coach
so you would like to play what would you
like to play in order to get rid of the
Knight on D4 who can tell me like what
is the most straightforward way of
trying to
get rid of this Knight
yeah it's to play C3 so you would have
to drop the Knight back to D1 why D1 in
order to defend the B2 pawn and then you
would want to play C3 but the problem is
you're giving black a bailout option you
can do all of this and then play C3 and
then black can simply trade the Knight
for E2 so you've wasted a bunch of Tempe
only to orchestrate a trade so the move
that you often see is Knight E2 to C1
looks terribly passive but the point is
then you play Knight D1 and then you
push C3 finally getting rid of this
Knight once and for all and then because
the position is closed you can afford to
do this you bring the knights back into
the game
I'm giving you just a general this I'm
not saying in this exact position but in
this exact position it is definitely a
legitimate idea so just trying to show
you the similarities between ideas and
across openings so after castles
similar concept here you literally can't
play C6 so you drop back the Knight
to E8 also defending the rook and then
you prepare C6 I I like Black's position
even though the engine seems to believe
that white is better after some sort of
trippy move C5
oh Knight C5 Bishop E7 skewer
Rook C6 and apparently after Knight EC3
black is having a lot of trouble against
this move Bishop B5 the night before
somehow Black's pieces are super
discombobulated but this is hard to find
and can heck water C5 and Bishop B7 is
super computer-ish and black can play
Rook D7 nothing wrong with this
and now apparently C6 so when you
analyze with an engine you get this very
disingenuous sense that white has this
huge initiative but finding all these
weird trippy moves is is really really
hard
like C5 C6 you have to find all these
like Bishop g57 type moves and it's just
not easy but I would start with castles
Knight DC3 is a little bit lackluster C6
so white decides to go after our Bishop
which is totally viable here is where I
think our opponent really made a series
of inaccuracies after which we claimed
the advantage once and for all does
anybody remember what suggestion I made
during the game what would I do here
with white very good you remember Bishop
G5 to E3 why because you want to control
the C5 square and you want to push the
pawn up to C5 to make it harder for
black to eventually access the square on
D4 I think Bishop E3 would be the
easiest way just to keep a decent
position for white position is probably
about equal Knight D7 is what I would
play
and then we would try to go Knight dc5
96 and 94. I would still prefer black
here but perhaps the skeptic quality
Bishop E2 Knight D7
and G4 is definitely a mistake after G4
I have no doubts that black is already
in charge why is G4 bad because the
Queens are off the board you should have
no attacking Ambitions here for white
and G4 just creates a gaping hole on F4
even though it might be hard to Envision
a knight landing on F4 as you could see
a knight of four check basically won the
game in the end so ironically like a lot
of White's problems can be traced
precisely to this move G4
so yeah G4 G4 is just unnecessary I mean
what would I do instead I'm in King F2
still Bishop E3 just make like a mundane
move cave in castles nothing wrong with
just casting playing Rook D1
and I just have a hard time believing
that white is all that much worse here
principle of two weaknesses comes into
play White can handle one weak square
but when there are two gaping weaknesses
that's when things become really
problematic okay folks if we could I I
would appreciate if we could focus on
the game and I'm always happy to answer
like more general questions afterward
so G4 is is definitely another mistake
we decided on night before is H6 ever a
move you can throw in so orange thing I
wouldn't play H6 remember that white
wants to bring the bishop to E3 anyway
so a lot of players have the problem
with these types of move where they
instinctually just play H6 it's a form
of one moveitis where does the instinct
to play H6 come from it comes from the
Instinct The Rush that you get of
inducing a retreating move but remember
the rules in such end games are totally
different you should never judge a move
based on whether it's retreating or not
here the bishop wants to retreat it
wants to access E3 and now you've
saddled yourself with another weakness
you can't play Bishop F6 as easily
you've actually done a lot of damage
with this move
another thing to remember is that you
have in such positions the general idea
of trading dark squared Bishops it
should make sense why if you trade dark
Spirit Bishops you lessen White's
ability to throw some weight on these
two incredibly weak squares now
previously I have shown y'all a game
that I won in the king's Indian in a
very similar type of position precisely
based on this plan if you'd like a
refresher here is the position you
should immediately be like wow this is
like really really similar structurally
to what to what I'm showing you right
now
okay so take a look at this position
this is an online game pro chess League
back when mere mortals like me could
play on the process league so I'm
playing Black what does the similarity
consist well again you can see this
asymmetry in the center where we have
the D4 square at our disposal although
it's defended by like a thousand pieces
and white does not have the D5 score
because we're protecting it with our C6
Pawn that is the nature of Black's
Advantage but we're a long way away from
being we can't just play Knight D4
and if you say oh let's play C5 well
then you've defeated the whole purpose
you've weakened the square on D5 and
you've allowed White's Knight to get
there So the plan is you want to trade
all of the pieces that defend the D4
Square now the rule can be contested
easily on demand we can play the move
Rook Ada but how do we get to this
bishop on E3 this is where I developed a
really nice plan who can either remember
or list a plan that allows black to
trade the bishop on E3 and I literally
just executed this plan move by move
like I just made one move second move
third move Bang
yeah very good Cross mirage got it you
definitely deserve a sub
H5
yh5 King H7
and Bishop H6 easy as that because the
center is closed you can afford to
invest three Tempe into this plan Force
the bishop trade and now already C5
makes a lot more sense because if white
plays Knight C3 we stick our Knight on
D4 and the Knight on F6 does a perfectly
good job of supervising the D5 Square
so a simple application of this idea of
trading off your opponent's best piece
again
should be fully understandable if you've
been paying attention
so let's go back to the game so this
circled around my mind
for a while but if we try to go Bishop
F6 here white is not going to accede to
the trade and that's why we started by
working on our Knights Knight before
Knight C5
get it around either to D3 and F4 or to
E6 and D4
96 so we just literally proceed with our
plan we stick our Knight on D4 we
solidify it by doubling our Rooks on the
D file
and we're threatening Knight takes C2
check and we now start working on our
other Knight the engine doesn't like
this move Knight A6 may be an inaccuracy
the engine likes night before it says
the best move so here the computer likes
Bishop F6 which is originally what I
wanted to play and I was worried about
G5 Bishop E7 and F4 oh but we can play
Knight takes E2 now
and the point why would you give up your
amazing night for the terrible Bishop
because you open up the D3 Square for
your other Knight here the idea is just
very concrete you're going to grab the
pawn on F4 this is just total
devastation I missed Knight takes C2 see
these details really make a huge
difference
instead we played Knight A6
which I still think maintains a serious
advantage and I think the beginning of
the end probably came okay still still
our opponent is playing decently I still
think B4 is fine
I still think this position is
defensible Knight G3 is the decisive
mistake because Knight G3 allows the
trade of dark-squared Bishops and once
the Bishops are gone these squares are
just going to kill white of course you
could have defended more resiliently
with Bishop G2 but now we could strike
at the other side with A5 and then Rook
a I mean you could just see White's
position crumbling before your eyes
but how would I play instead well I
think it's probably time for white to
take the Knight on D4 I think there's no
other choice
because if Knight takes D4 then black no
longer has access to the G5 Square we
would have taken with a pawn
and perhaps played a move like Bishop E5
to control the F4 square with the minor
pieces
but
white can hold I think here I can
probably hold on with something like
Bishop C4 and
you know great drawing chances if white
is very careful but that's always going
to be true when you're trying to grind
your opponent out in some end game
they're always going to have drawing
chances if they defend carefully so the
takeaway from this game there's a couple
the first is that you you always have to
look at a position not just from the
perspective of immediate peace placement
oh the Knight on D5 is really strong
white is better you have to look at it
from the long-term perspective of who
controls most of the key squares in the
center
if you want a specific tip then this
king's Indian structure with the pawns
on e4 and C4 and the pawn gone from D4
can be a huge liability for white
eventually black will get a knight to D4
in many such cases notice the the idea
of going 98 and C6 to chase the Knight
out of D5 and of course the patience
that it takes to play such a position
nothing happens fast here we create a
general plan like we won a night on D4
then we decide on the most efficient way
of getting it there the night before
Knight C5 and we basically just followed
through on our plans we made a
combination of moves that either are
part of the plan or just generally
improve our position like Rook cd8
Knight A6 right these are moves that
should make a lot of sense to so in
closed positions you don't need to
overthink it just ask yourself can I
make substantive improvements to my
pieces can I trade one of my bad pieces
from my opponent's good pieces can I
make the weak squares in my opponent's
pieces more accessible to my pieces
but those are some questions you can ask
yourself to handle these closed
positions and on that note we're going
to wrap up the game now one very
ambitious project that I have undertaken
is to annotate all of my speedrun games
that's going to take a while but that's
something that I can definitely sell as
a kind of addendum
all games annotated in a PGN file
so I'm already a couple of games through
but it's going to take me a while to do
that but I want to do it myself I want
to annotate them myself
so it's it's been amazing to see the
kind of support the speedrun videos get
so yeah two more speed on videos that
will come out on this one and then we'll
start with a clean slate next time so
thanks everybody for your support and
the subs I'll also be doing the next end
game video to come out pretty soon so
lots of stuff to look forward to
and uh thanks for hanging out thanks for
the support everybody
see you later
[Music]